we don't have slow-mo so we got to do a
foot dude check check out the
dexterity fut stman no do the ridge foot
little it dirty what super foot
Wallace super foot
[Music]
Wallace welcome back everybody to
another sick ass episode of off the
Record and today we've got funny Jeremy
in the
building
Bart almost introduced my introduction I
mean interrupted my introduction but you
should have interrupted yourself you you
laughed at yourself just shut up dude
you laugh and I was what is that a small
on you why are you wearing a small yeah
it's tiny shirt IDI cuz it's big Shir
check it out
yeah you want to look buff that being
said what's up Jeremy what's up dude
everybody knows you here
Jeremy Sensei Jeremy Legends Legends
Sensei Jeremy Sensei San Jose Weir cuz
that's like not a thing to me what do
you mean I don't know I I've always like
watched you guys on YouTube like as a
kid growing up like I said I would be
like laughing in the corner and just
remember that guy all
yes shut on camera show on camera that's
how I know Bart right growing
up no we came up in the circuits
together oh yeah totally we came up and
the in the kks
St no circuits yeah tkk K
D no but I mean it's just weird it's
it's cool it's like a little full circle
for me so thank you for having me Si
dude thanks for coming man well you're
the man dude you're a legend in the the
stunt space in the stunt space so I here
I mean I hope not a legend yeah I'm
young man I got a young Legend is kind
of cool no but you're still older than
than than the neck am I older than you
how old are you how old are you I'm 31 I
just turned 31 everybody's older than 31
[__] you dude take that back wait time
out you're 34 and that's still
considered young for the space it's not
no that I've been doing stunts for 15
years dude Legend leg Legend you know
I'm talking about young Legend I was
like the uh I was like right out of high
school like went straight to ninja
school that's cool how did you get into
it most people don't like oh people want
to be the star they don't want to be
like know about Ninja School how do you
enroll that like how many credits do you
need for Ninja's like no one's dream is
to be the
henchman but your well I mean [__] like
everybody wanted to be Jackie Chan right
yeah and I was like I'm going to be
better than Jackie chant like when I was
a kid my confidence level was like
through the roof I was as it should be I
would be watching stuff and I'd be like
I could do that I haven't even done it
yet like I could do that I do that and
then like but i' beting marshmallows
these guys suck but I'd be the idiot who
actually go out and do it so like I
remember my my grandma yelled at me cuz
I was like 11 and we had this little
grassy area in front of the house and I
like climbing houses I would chill on
top of houses so like you know my
grandma had this little one-story house
and she came out one day and I was like
doing side flips into the grass and I
was 11 and she was like I didn't even
know you could do that
I I just saw it and then just doing
Falls cuz then I wouldn't I wouldn't do
the progression thing that they do now
like I learned how to do progressions to
teach so it became a really good teacher
but I didn't have a progression I were
you just good at like just just cuz it's
so scary to like do a lot of those moves
well so I would go I go I could do that
and then if I can't I'm tough like
that's that was my mentality that's a
good mentality so I would are you just
missing that one thing in your brain
where you just have like no fear cuz we
fear Everyone We Fear everyone fear
everyone is that what that says yeah
yeah it almost does you want to get one
you going to join the group wait do you
all have that y nope
what bar has it on both on the sh of all
he has it on
both double fear everyone we're very
afraid of everyone I like that as a
model though I like that we also have a
screw loose you you should though
because if people don't have [__]
manners anymore you know what I mean
like we're just talking outside like
everybody does MMA these days everybody
knows how to do Jiu-Jitsu jit everyone
knows how to shoot shoot everyone owns a
gun right everyone goes a ter tactical
ter Tactical YouTubers go to teren yeah
especially the only fans girls they know
how to shoot everybody know how to shoot
yeah everybody can shoot so like now
more than ever everybody's got to be
good at martial arts I was just an idiot
who was like yeah I could do that and
then if I don't I'll be okay I'd smash
my face a couple times and I'd be like
that sucked I don't want that happening
again so one one technical question for
all the like Layman like the idiot fans
like myself out there when you talk
about like uh you learned progressions
to teach like what's a progression so
like if you wanted to learn a 540 kick
right sure what is that uh it's where
you do in in teeko it's called a tornado
kick uh where you spin and you jump off
your front foot spin 360 in the air and
kick right 540 you would land on your
kicking leg and so some people do it
with a round kick or uh inside cres does
it look like
thisum you
kick that's true land on this L yeah
yeah yeah yeah you to you had to get up
to show us that wow you could have just
did this I think Ste I think Steve does
a version of that no I'm I'm I'm showing
you guys so you guys have a get a better
visual than a chair we don't have
slow-mo so we got to do a my [__]
foot dude check check out the
dexterity future St man no do the ridge
foot it's a little bit dirty what super
foot
Wallace super foot Wallace
okay so the progression of that for
example so for example is you would
learn the step right and then uh you
would learn the kick by itself without
the spin and then you okay so it's like
what it's like what people be doing on
Tik Tok nowadays where they're like
learn this trick right here and then
they do it and then you think you could
do it cuz it looks easy but you can't
yeah you did it in 30 seconds yeah so
like as a kid I didn't I didn't know
that it was either do or don't got it so
like the reason I started martial arts
cuz my dad caught me one day and I was
doing a tornado kick and I was three and
he was like that's [__] crazy where'd
you do that where where' you learn that
and I was like we always watch Bruce Lee
together and I just did it and he was
like okay you're going to taekwondo so
went to taekwondo we couldn't afford it
so I left Taekwondo after 2 months Tako
is a money scam huh it's a [__] they
got like 12 belts before you're like age
four cuz they just want to [__] make
you pay for testing keeps you in there
and even if you suck they give you the
belt cuz they want you to feel like you
can move to the next belt then each belt
has another [__] stripe stripe stripe
all right dude you're exposing too much
yeah it's a scam did you not move up
look no I got second degree black belt
but I never deserved it oh [__] that's
what I'm saying it's a sick it's a sick
I must have invested a lot well the
thing about martial arts like what
people forget is like you paying rent
right so until you prove yourself in a
competition or something then you're
you're a guy that's why when people are
like Jeremy you're a dick when you teach
cuz I'm really hard on people and I'm
like no no no I want to be good just
like the old Asian Dad would be like no
you have to be good right but like in
the American like Western Society like
nobody's used to that they're like oh
you have to be nice you have to let them
progress on their own and but then you
have to let them pass the test and get
their yellow belts with their friends
like that makes no sense everybody's
progressing on their own and then
getting the belt at the same time what
what are we teaching them like you know
what I mean so anyways they I was always
a hard one right and and I I push people
um but I had to learn how to be
Progressive and like do a nice
progression for when I train actors and
stuff like that but oh cuz actors are
weak bro no no no
no yeah which one's the weakest they're
more they're just more in touch with
their emotions actors complain all the
time bro oh my God this water is not as
cold as
it can't do anything right a complain
they can't even finish the
sentence they thr theirs up oh [__] this
I think we have it good though with our
actors cuz like I think everybody by now
has seen all the BTS of John Wick oh
yeah everybody seen keani so now every
time people walk into our gym with the
blue floor they're like well I can't
[__] up
ke so like we've been getting really
lucky a great bar to set yeah yeah I
don't think I've had like a bad attitude
actor since like but keano doesn't seem
like a diva I mean like there's all
these stories about how humble he is
like there's all these like articles I
read out of nowhere where like look at
him and there's a picture of him just
chilling on a subway like a normal human
being that there like 50 photos him just
him on the subway yeah did you see the
video that just came out where he got
pissed off some guy was like forcing him
yeah he he was like forcing him to give
a autograph and the guy was like I get
it man he's like no you don't get the
[__] point and then still signed it
throws it and he's like I just want time
to myself but it's like an eBay guy it
wasn't like a fan it was like it like a
reseller yeah those guys are so they
hunt you down with stacks and then
they'll just be like here sign this but
he still signed it yeah he still signed
still signed it what a nice guy what a g
I would have given him the bird and I
would have walked away I would been like
no like I'm ke Reeves I can't punch you
so you get one of these so who's that
bad attitude in 2015 just first name is
okay
oh it starts with r rulu yeah exactly
Remo Remo Williams Remo Williams bro
Remo Remo got a good attitude take that
back it's
Remo those
stupid oh
god oh that was so
fast oh that's good I was so intimidated
coming here too cuz I was like comedians
are so intimidating why you guys are so
fast I'm not a comedian [__] no I'm
not I never did a standup show that's
fair didn't you do a standup show at the
last as Uncle
chin was wasn't him man straight that
was B took a standup class and did a
standup show that's deflecting I went
and clapped yeah it was good did you say
that's deflecting it is what is your
favorite alltime martial arts movie do
you have a I hate this question really
why cuz I hate martial arts movies but
that's what got you into it though
didn't it get you into it don't like it
like that was my child there stunts and
romcoms well that's the thing like
usually like wo whoa whoa whoo is it one
of those things where because you work
behind the curtain it's been kind of
ruined for you cuz you're too not at all
like when I see a movie that I like
because I know what it takes now now I
appreciate it more oh okay like for the
most part when you say like Marshall
arts movies I like I like like I get
into my feels and stuff so three ninjas
yeah [__] yeah yeah dude that's a good
Market bro that's my favorite one Tong
why you always eating stuff you know
when they're running on the the boards
on the water you remember oh the Japan
one I tried that so many times just as a
kid I would just set up cardboard not
thinking it's not waterproof just to the
bottom
soggy that that movie blew my mind the
Japanese one yeah cuz I was like I
growing up I watch Le Bruce Lee all that
stuff and it was always these moves are
done by adults yeah and then when I saw
three ninjas I was like wait I can do
this yeah that's crazy or Surf Ninjas
like NJ or Sidekicks Sid kicks dude who
had asthma and I was like Yo dude I can
relate I have a breathing problem too
he's the geek I was like he's kind of a
loser
too Sidekicks with asthma what no no
sidekick the dude with Chuck Norris
every single time he had like an asthma
Faith he would go into like his fantasy
of like being a psychic to Chuck Norris
remember no I know but it's just funny
how you were like yeah he's kind of a
loser too it makes him kind of cool like
imagine like your your stick was like I
could do Sidekicks and I have
asthma no they made asthma seem way
dorkier than it is yeah you didn't grow
up on like [__] you guys like vanam
movies and like no I did though I did
though but like but you you seen so much
now it's like favorite let's say like
when I was a kid I loved um Unleashed
because which one's that one Unleashed
Danny the dog because J jetley was like
this man dog who they would like take
off the collar and he would go and you
know kill people then you like look at
it and you're like it's not a good movie
it's not my favorite movie oh I see I'd
rather watching glorious bastards as a
kid though as a kid it's different
that's also why you watch martial arts
sometimes right you don't watch it for
like how sick the acting is yeah that's
true that's true know man my favorite
movie as a kid was blood sport okay and
then as an adult when you watch it it's
so good cuz it's funny yeah there's this
one scene where he [__] slices his
hat right cuz he's trying to steal the
sword he slices his hat and then he has
like a like a montage into like some
like Daydreams or whatever and then you
realize there's like act one act two act
there's like [__] that thing is way
his [__] Daydream is way too long and
you're like what the [__] I could have
sworn it was like 30 seconds but it was
like 15 15 minutes then he comes back to
like with this French
accent you're like what the [__] why is
that his head
though that's how the French talk right
after his hat glass slice he's just been
standing in the room like this like as
an adult it's so [__] dumb but as a
kid it's when I watch it I still have
kid eyes when I watch it hey did you
ever [__] Like Glue rocks to your
hands after K boxing [__] put honey
and [__] and broken glass yeah that's
sick it was so fun I guess for me it was
like Rumble in the Bronx Rubble
the that's my Bible dude cuz I mean
where's Angelo where is he you said
there's no good acting in yeah dude what
about the kid bro the kid's my favorite
yeah
K my chair I wish my legs were like
other kids I remember I had to I had to
[__] pause that movie you know when
he threw the homie through the wood
chipper I remember I was like I don't
feel I'm going to be
sick no way yeah cuz I was like that's
[__] crazy that made you queasy yep
that guy got
shredded I had a fear that like randomly
a gang was going to stick me in an alley
and like fat bottles at me fat bottles
dude and like like yeah that movie had
everything it had a hot Asian girl you
had like a minority making it in New
York beating people up or and a
hovercraft and a hovercraft hovercraft
Next Level our boss is not white
tiger that's the best line doesn't it
start with him like being um
handstanding in apartment yeah and he's
doing he's doing Muk Jong and stuff dude
and he opens the door yeah that movie is
so good it's so good man the bottom I
didn't rewatch it so that's your
favorite ROM LeBron I would I would say
because for me it wasn't so like we're
trying to do kung fu it was like the
it's just the story yeah the story like
it was cool that I remember having a
crush on the chick yep uh and then
learning how to jump from things all the
time like I didn't have a two-story
house so my my uncle had one so I would
jump from the the stairs to
anywhere oh my God yeah I would just hop
The Rail and try to make it to the couch
how many broken bones you got um I broke
my ankle but that was until I was an
adult um I had a bone chip in my knee
but again adult I've separated my
shoulder adult been a conscious just a
bunch of times from all the stunts
you've done usually not what yeah it's
like in training or yeah so I mean our
our biggest job like if if you ever like
like a lot of our videos talk about what
it takes to be a stunk eyee our our main
thing is how to do it make it look
dangerous and be safe so if I get hurt
or if anybody gets hurt it we take that
as a fail it's not like what you think
where it's like yeah I'm tough do stunts
right it is like there's a point to
where you know things can only be so
safe like if I'm going to hit you with a
car I got to hit you with the car like
you you you do what you can you wear
your pads and you you do a couple test
runs but but there's a point where you
you just face the music and you go I
signed the contract today let's go how
many times have you been hit by a car
dude in John Wick alone probably like
just in the fourth one just in the
fourth one I probably did like just in
the roundabout scene yeah four five
that's the craziest scene ever dude like
that [__] was so so on John Wick the
safety thing that we did was um Chad
wanted us to be able to do wers cuz
usually in a you watch a TV a one like
long takes one so Chad's like the crazy
guy who's like anything that takes a lot
of people like people to do a big setup
like one car hit right usually you do
one car hit and then it's like cross
your fingers one car hit okay cut is he
okay okay good Well Chad was like I want
to be able to do three to four car hits
in a section where ke Reeves is weaving
through traffic and fighting Jesus
Christ God I got with our stunt
coordinators like like Scott Rogers and
and Steven dun leevy and we coordinated
with our riggers like we built this
platform that had two cars that were on
sleds or like um tracks that would just
go by the push of a button wow and and
then we put that next to a spring floor
and then next to that was like a wooden
platform where real cars could drive and
so we would start with a real car hit
and then as he was fighting as he was
going through those um sled the cars on
sleds they were just padded pieces of
wood and then they would CG cars onto it
and so you would set the speed of those
cars and then what we would do is we had
people on wires so in the middle of all
these cars going through and then
fighting I would I would be able to go
okay camera's going to go over here this
guy's going to hit get hit by the car we
F follow Keanu that way shoot that that
guy Dodge this car step in front get hit
by the CG car and I mean it was still it
was kind of sketchy cuz as stunk guy I
don't know why this is weird but when we
were getting the Japanese guys the
French guys and the German guys to get
hit by the fake cars everybody's more
sketched out because we're so used to
getting hit by real
cars you know when you go to uh Six
Flags and you hear the Superman [__]
yeah that's what they sounded like
that's scary as hell unfamiliar like it
was unfamiliar sound so you felt like a
puppy going like where's it com where is
it coming and you're like trying to
fight Keanu and shoot and look like a
badass but you hear it you're like here
it
comes boom and you would take those hits
so the timing is also not what you're
used to cuz you're used to just a car
moving you're not training with sleds
and you're used to yeah I mean for me
like working with stun people so I I got
to do like lxd stuff with John shu M oh
yeah so I knew how to like do stuff on
account I knew how to like that's their
system yeah and I knew okay so now like
usually we're like okay the ballet
dancers is going to come out while the
crumpers do this and the B boys do that
right and so for me it was like okay our
playground is this cars are going that
way okay Kean is got to make it this way
so in the first few beats he's got to
have pass three cars those three cars
are going to be the visual queue for the
first guy to come out he gets shot oh
and every piece of the equation is just
like choreographing dance how how many
times do you have to like or how long of
choreograph practice do you have to do
before like okay let's do our first take
okay so there's a lot of political stuff
that went on on John Wick 4 so I had to
create that fight scene within 3 days
before we shot it Jesus Christ three
days I created that with uh we had a
French team um their coordinator was
lauron um he kind of had yeah laon he's
dope and then we had a German team and I
feel like every time you say someone's
name I go I hear a guy like I see a guy
pop out
online thanks for the plug bad laon and
then uh we had Koji from Japan and then
coolest names ever Jesus Christ so we
all like my job was like I didn't just
choreograph everything like I would my
job is to take the ideas of everybody
and then make them work right make it
cohesive and so
um in the three days like Chad was like
I need this done by this day I'm like
[__] so I've got to work with the
riggers to to do the timing with the CG
uh car hits we wanted them to have a
little extra pop so we' pop them on the
hit and we pull them out and see where
they fly or try to coordinate where
they're going to land and um yeah it was
nuts and how that set how long of
rehearsal do you guys need I mean we
didn't like that show that movie
happened so fast in my brain yeah the
way Chad Works we're on such a he's on a
such a high uh frequency when he works
and you either keep up or you fall off
and when you're keeping up [__] happens
so fast that all of a sudden you're at
rap and you're like what did I just do
with my life and then you count back
like I got hit by five cars I fell down
20 stairs I [__] I did this many wi
gags I got bit by [__] you know three
dogs 40 times like oh [__] dude Jer you
died like 20 times in yeah and and
honestly I didn't even die the most like
we have a guy like Bruce who's on my
team Bruce and Lee uh sorry Lee is
Chinese these ts are the coolest names
CH Lee Chang or Chang Lee he's uh he's
Chinese guy and then Bruce uh conception
they died the most like they were in
every scene you know a guy named Bruce
conception con Filipino from he's from
like yeah dude another
gu and those guys actually died more
than me cuz the thing was like when we
did the sequence in the Japan the Osaka
Continental um Chad wanted a bunch of
escalator Falls and we actually oh yeah
that's the worst and to be honest you
know people watch John Wick movies and
they go ah it's too much action [__] the
first cut that I watched to the end
we've cut out 30 to 40 minutes
just punching and kicking action like
shooting and stuff
what an extended version just like
[__] bleeding from watching just bone
breaks yeah so like like we actually we
actually a lot of our [__] didn't make
it in like there was one there was one
stunt where I did like um I did like a
14t uh scoi like from from a railing
onto like a traditional Japanese table
oh and the table was Breakaway but
nobody like the the Outer Perimeter of
it was like real like teak wood or
something and my from 14 ft smacking
your ankle like that and going through a
breakaway table like that was bad oh my
God couldn't walk correctly for like 2
weeks but Chad on in that sequence he
was like you're not allowed to do any
escalator Falls like you remember the
one that went viral the guy flying down
the escalators he I was like I'll do it
he's like you can't I'm like why he's
like if you get hurt this is the first
sequence in the movie like I need you
for the rest of the show you're you're
coordinating things you're not just
dying it's like okay fine and then we
get and then in the middle of like
winter in Germany we're doing the French
the the Arctic Triumph scene we're
getting hit by cars and I'm like you
letting me get hit by a
cars but I couldn't fall down escalator
he would just he' just laugh he's just
like well he's like as the show goes on
I can I can bet more like like okay well
if he gets hurt we only have this
sequence left or if he gets hurt it's
you know you're just bartering with him
for how many times you can die jeez I'll
get set on fire five times if I get hit
by a car this is an amazing conversation
we're going to have to cut this video
and go into a part two though because
we're all [__] fascinated just
kidding news careful Bo is a brand just
kidding news is the man of smart people
the people of just kidding news careful
boys they are very smart just kidding
news the number one podcast in the world